It was certainly understandable why so
many Dexter fans were skeptical of Dexter:
New Blood when Showtime first
announced plans for the series.
The last episode of "Dexter" is one of the
most universally despised series finales
in the history of television. However,
over the course of its first season,
Dexter: New Blood would seem to have proven
itself a valued continuation of the original
series. The penultimate episode of the reboot's
first season, Episode 9 "The Family Business",
currently sits at a 9.7 out of 10 rating on
IMDb, certainly a far cry from the original
series finale of Dexter, which is currently
only managing 4.6 stars on the same site.
As reviews and reactions for the finale
of Dexter: New Blood continue to flood in,
it will be interesting to see if fans of the
series prefer this as a more definitive ending
or want to see it as the first part
of a new entry of the franchise.
Here's a quick explainer about where
the last episode leaves things.
Originally introduced as the kind-hearted
owner of a local business, Kurt Caldwell,
played by Clancy Brown, is slowly revealed
to be a monster who murders helpless women.
Even though Michael C. Hall’s Dexter Morgan
kills and dismembers Kurt in Episode 9,
the late serial killer's presence still looms
large over the events of the season finale.
Before he winds up sealed in plastic, Kurt
sets fire to Dexter's cabin and mails Iron
Lake Police Chief Angela Bishop a letter
that proves Dexter killed Matt Caldwell.
Kurt's final actions are very reminiscent of
those of Arthur Mitchell (aka Trinity) played
by John Lithgow in the Season 4 finale of the
original Dexter series. In that episode, Dexter
murders Trinity and returns home only to discover
that Trinity has already murdered his wife, Rita,
and left his son, Harrison, crying in a pool of
blood. Despite technically winning the battle,
few would contest that Dexter
ultimately lost the war with Trinity.
Similarly, Kurt's letter to Angela and his
subsequent burning of Dexter's cabin directly lead
to Dexter's arrest in the finale. As she stands
over the smoldering remnants of Dexter's cabin,
Angela locates a titanium screw that previously
held Matt's leg together. With all the proof
she needs, Angela arrests Dexter for murder and
makes a quick call to one Angel Batista of the
Miami Metro Police Department. Once again,
Dexter's enemy bests him from the beyond.
After decades of murder and dismemberment, Dexter
finally meets his own end in the last moments of
Dexter: New Blood. The final episode sees the
famous serial killer cornered at all angles by
his former girlfriend, who promises to extradite
the infamous Bay Harbor Butcher to Florida,
where he will surely face the death penalty.
Unwilling to accept his fate, Dexter makes a
mad-dash escape from the jail, leaving a bloody
trail in the process. Dexter rushes to Harrison,
but the elder Morgan's killing of Sergeant
Logan is a step too far for the young
serial killer in training, who recognizes
that Dexter's actions violate the code.
At his son's urging, Dexter considers the
plethora of innocent people who have died as
a result of his actions. We see flashes of Logan,
LaGüerta, Doakes, Lundy, Harry, Rita, and Debra,
all people who suffered untimely deaths because of
their proximity to Dexter. Faced with the truth of
his past, Dexter admits that Harrison is right and
invites his son to shoot him in the chest. While
not exactly the same as showrunner Clyde Phillips'
original plan for the Dexter series finale,
the highlighting of Dexter's truly innocent
victims represents a similar narrative choice in
that he is finally forced to take responsibility
for his actions, just prior to his own death.
Throughout Dexter and Dexter: New Blood, Dexter
makes it clear that he is unable to feel genuine
emotion, despite how normal he may seem to
some people. In Season 1, Episode 1, he says,
"People fake a lot of human interactions,
but I feel like I fake them all,
and I fake them very well."
By the end of the series,
Dexter admits that his emotional mimicry and
violent urges will always hurt those close to him.
He abandons Harrison to spare him the
suffering. In furtherance of this goal,
Dexter also initially refuses to have anything
to do with Harrison when he arrives in Iron Lake.
However, despite pleas from Debra's postmortem
manifestation, Dexter eventually embraces
Harrison as a son, teaching him the code
and even inviting him into his kill room.
Sadly, Debra's pleas would seem to have been
well founded. The code is ultimately proven
unable to prevent Dexter from harming numerous
innocent people. Realizing that Dexter is the
person responsible for most of the suffering in
his life, Harrison openly blames his father for
his mother's murder, his aunt's death, and
his own dark tendencies. Harrison screams,
"Open your eyes and look at what you've done!"
Slowly, Dexter comes to grips with the truth
in Harrison's words, telling his son that he
deserves a better life and a better father. Just
before Harrison shoots his father, Dexter notes,
"I've never really felt
love. Real love. Until now."
It has certainly taken some time for
him to learn, but Dexter's final moments
seem to offer him some understanding
of what it means to actually be human.
It's difficult to tell where things could
go after this type of a finale. With the
titular character dead, the future seems somewhat
limited. Of course, any speculation about any more
potential seasons of Dexter: New Blood is bound
to focus on Harrison, who leaves Iron Lake with
no specific destination in mind. As he departs
Iron Lake, Harrison reads an old letter written
by Dexter to Hannah McKay, in which his father
affectionately refers to Harrison as his, quote,
"phantom limb" and says that a normal
life will never be possible for him,
so long as he is around. While one interpretation
of this scene is that Harrison can live a normal
life now that his father is dead, a darker
interpretation is also equally likely.
Harrison has previously displayed a multitude
of dark tendencies, much like his father. It's
unclear if Harrison will be able to hold his Dark
Passenger at bay without his father's assistance.
However normal Harrison manages to make his
future, that voice which guides him could,
at some point, take on the form of a
familiar face. In the original series,
Dexter's Dark Passenger is represented by
his deceased father and mentor, Harry Morgan.
Given Dexter's role in his son's life, it's
possible that Harrison's memory of his father
could one day occupy the same function.
That voice in the finale might just be
the beginning of Dexter's own postmortem
manifestation inside Harrison's head.
While a show called "Harrison" probably
wouldn't have quite the same appeal as
"Dexter," perhaps someone out there
is already trademarking something like
"Dexter: Afterlife" with this very plan in mind.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don’t miss a single one.